this is history making in canada a press
conference to announce a milestone in
addressing mistreatment and
discrimination against first nations
families i'm very pleased to announce
that canada and the parties have reached
two significant agreements in principle
one that provides fair and equitable
compensation to first nations children
and families harmed by discriminatory
underfunding and the other addressing
the long-term term reform that's needed
for the first nations child and family
services program
it's been almost 15 years since canada's
human rights tribunal ruled child and
family services had discriminated
against first nations children leaving
hundreds of thousands suffering trauma
and spiraling into poverty
billions in compensation
in an agreement in principle and still
for those affected
it is mostly an important step forward
we have a long way to go
to address the poverty in our nations
and no amount of money will ever be the
right amount nor will it bring back a
childhood lost but today is about
acknowledgement about being seen and
heard
children taken from their families and
put into a system underfunded and
ill-equipped to deliver the basics of
life led to generational trauma harm and
loss this milestone announcement cannot
turn back the clock but if solidified by
the deadline we'll build the framework
the agreements in principle we have
signed today will support first nations
children so that they can have the same
opportunities to grow up
with their families and communities
thriving through their cultures and
languages
as a next step
and a difficult one canada and the
parties will negotiate a final
settlement agreement which will map out
how compensation will flow to first
nations children and families will
establish a framework for long-term
funding to improve
services for children and families
the parties have until march 31st to
finalize the agreement jody vance al
jazeera vancouver